hi everybody it's been a while since
i've talked about the books i've been
reading lately last time i talked about
recent books i've read my hair looked
like this it hasn't been a totally
consistent reading situation just based
on how
busy everything's been with school and
work and it's kind of been like what
i've been reading throughout while i
read the wheel of time with longer books
i really need to take a break it can get
stale when you're in the same genre all
the time at least it does for me the
first book is
forbidden knowledge by stephen r
donaldson this is the second book in the
gap cycle series it is very good uh
donaldson i think is a kind of
overlooked writer he wrote
the chronicles of thomas covenant series
in the 70s i believe i think what martin
was doing with this grim dark
fantasy stuff donaldson was doing with
science fiction the real story the first
one is a very short um kind of
introduction to the series especially
graphic uh content so the second book
forbidden knowledge is when things
really
shift drastically and it takes a slower
pace something i love about this book in
the series is that it's really taking
these kind of space opera tropes and
flipping them on their head a little bit
and the real story she is rescued by
this guy takes her away from this
horrible horrible you know human it's
supposed to be a wonderful situation
well it's not he's also horrible mourn
basically has been planted with a device
in her head is like this remote that has
total access to her brain infinite
pleasure infinite pain it can take away
the need for sleep basically it takes
away your willpower she's in control of
the remote through most of the second
book it's kind of like a superpower
there's just so many moments that blew
my mind that had me going how is this
happening it seems so ridiculous at some
points that it's like this shouldn't be
readable yet it is it's just amazing and
i've been kind of waiting to start the
next book because i have so much other
reading to do really excited to read a
dark and hungry god who rises the third
book in the series and also like the
best book title ever another book i read
and you guys know i love elmore leonard
i love
his type of crime fiction that is like
funny and fast-paced and very dialogue
heavy before he got known for crime
writing he wrote westerns this is just
an excellent revenge story called valdez
is coming
town constable in arizona i think it's
in phoenix actually valdez is a very
good guy he's trying to get compensation
for a woman whose husband they
wrongfully murdered valdez is repeatedly
humiliated and eventually they time up
to a crucifix and make him walk and then
they tip him over on his back and he's
just like left in the sun to scorch and
fun just seeing this one person go up
against 40 guys it explores a lot of the
racism at the time what i really love
about elmore leonard's westerns
especially there's a lot of interest in
people who
were like marginalized or on the fringe
of society back then people who weren't
represented well in the you know like
western media or whatever i read the
great hunt this was a while ago i have a
dedicated review for that so i'm not
going to talk uh i'm not going to talk
anymore about it we'll say i don't think
i liked it as much as the eye of the
world but i did very much enjoy it and
one of the crime books that i was really
interested in reading was called the
hunter by richard stark which is a
pseudonym for donald e westlake so
donald lee westlake was a crime rider
famous series was the dorkmunder series
but he wrote under a ton of different
pseudonyms
richard stark was probably his most
prominent one where he wrote the parker
novels huge series it's funny stephen
king used richard stark for inspiration
when writing the dark half the pseudonym
for the writer in the dark half is stark
i believe stephen king's a fan of uh
westlake so i decided to give him a shot
also westlake wrote i believe he
co-wrote the the movie
the stepfather yeah it's very brutal
it's
it's very much of its time for sure
because there's a lot of stuff that's
like oh no this would not fly today the
character parker is so sociopathic like
you want to be really excited for his
revenge and you do because he's wrong
it's a story about a thief who is you
know wronged and left for dead and he
basically comes back to life to take
revenge and all he wants is to take
revenge but the more you read the story
the more you read like oh he was asking
for this like he was going to do the
same thing to him hypocrisy while he's
trying to take his revenge he'll just
like accidentally murder a person what
can you do
got to take my revenge in some ways it
reminded me of like michael myers in a
way because he's so emotionless
single-minded purpose crushes people
with his hands when i saw how many books
there are i'm like how could you write
this character this many times so real
quick i just want to cover what i'm
currently reading uh the hot rock which
is by donald westlake westlake was
trying to write another parker novel but
it was too silly he was like i can't
really write this this isn't really a
parker book anymore so he decided to
write as donald westlake we know with
humor and books and funny books it's
kind of can be hard sometimes to find a
good balance but i really enjoy the
humor in it so i'm going to keep reading
it's called the hot rock currently
reading the dragon reborn also song of
susanna i'm nearly done i don't know why
it's taking me so long the song of
susana is actually very good i really
like it oh one i just started recently
called how's the pain and i just the
opening scene of this book is
so fantastic it just opened so many
possibilities and it's a short read and
with a title like that how's the pain
so there's a few dnf's i want to talk
about
one is a ragin harlem by chester heims i
believe i really liked this don't know
exactly why i dnf'd when there's so much
other stuff that you're reading
sometimes it's just things fall by the
wayside i do want to finish this one day
it's very depressing actually that's
part of what was maybe harder to get
through the chalk circle man which is by
another french crime writer called fred
vargas has some of the
most interesting funny and unique
dialogue i've ever read i'm definitely
going to finish it so yeah that's kind
of what i've been reading i hope you are
all having a good
reading time of the year i feel like my
reading always drops off near the end of
the year and picks up in january just
because of how busy things get yeah have
a good one